welcome everyone
good evening my name is Priya natrajan
I'm an astrophysicist and I'm the
current director of the Frankie program
in science and the humanities
we are delighted to host today's event
that represents the Confluence literally
of Art and Science
we will see a wonderful story unfold on
screen
the story of the Lost Leonardo and we
have the absolute pleasure of the
protagonist
the artist and conservator Professor
Diane modestini in the audience with us
today and she will be speaking at the
end of the showing of this documentary
and we'll have a wonderful conversation
and Q a from all of you and we're also
delighted following the documentary to
have one of our own Dr Irma paseri who
will be joining uh this discussion
before I start I would like to
um
thank our benefactors Mr and Mrs Richard
and Barbara Frankie
uh for making possible not just this
Flagship interdisciplinary program at
Yale but many other events and
activities that cross-disciplinary
boundaries and enable new Innovative
conversations across silos in the
academic setting
I'm required to give you this notice
that this event is being recorded
photographed for educational archival
and promotional purposes including use
and print on the internet and other
forms of media by attending this event
today you agree to the possibility of
your voice or likeness captured by these
means and used for such purposes without
compensation to you and hereby wave any
related rights of privacy or publicity
so I also want to remind you following
the event we will have a reception
upstairs in the student lounge room 131
immediately afterward
so on to today's
wonderful speaker
Diane Dwyer modestini she's a clinical
professor in the crest program in
paintings and conservation emerta at
nyu's Institute of Fine Arts she's an
internationally renowned conservator of
Master and 19th century paintings she
received a ba in art history from
Barnard in 1968 after graduation she
spent a year in Florence where she
studied drawing at the Academia de bella
arti and Italian in later years she was
to written return often to this beloved
City where in 1996 she began and
directed The restoration program at the
Villa La Pietra she's on the board of
the foundation Roberto longi in Florence
she obtained an M.A and a certificate of
advanced study in art conservation from
the State University of New York
she was appointed the assistant
conservator of paintings at the
Metropolitan Museum of Art where she was
responsible for the collection of
American paintings in the preparation of
the reopening of the American wing
Miss modestini was engaged by the Samuel
Kress foundation in 1983 to undertake a
comprehensive survey of Crest paintings
that had been donated to 18 museums
around the United States in 1961 under
the foundation's regional Gallery
program in the late 1980s she initiated
a pilot class combining the results of
her ongoing survey of the dispersed
Crest collection and her new role as an
educator the success of the class led to
the launch of the Samuel H Chris program
in paintings and conservation in 1989.
the purpose of the to tell you a little
bit about this program because it's
incredibly unique the purpose of the
crest program is to provide students
with an opportunity to complete the
study and restoration of a painting
under the guidance of Miss modestini
assisted by a Crest fellow a young
professional conservator in the context
of an advanced treatment class
and this is what is in store As a treat
for those of us science Geeks as well
who love art and our science Geeks with
the progress of instrumental analysis
and the burgeoning interest in the study
of materials and techniques amongst art
historians the course has expanded to
include many technical topics including
the study of polarized light microscopy
and cross-sectional analysis of paint
samples to identify pigments and
non-destructive identification of their
constituents with x-ray fluorescence and
sem EDS Imaging with the ultraviolet
digital x-ray radiography infrared lift
reflectography and multiband
reflectography are also employed in May
2017 Miss morestini received a doctor of
Humane letters honoris causa from
Fairfield University
her book masterpieces on the life and
work of Mario modestini was published in
2018. so this introduction was just to
give you a sense of the incredibly
illustrious career that Professor
modestini has had and put for you in the
context what you are going to see in
this absolutely wonderful documentary
where very much like a scientist
she uncovered she had this moment of
Discovery so I'm dying to ask her more
about this when we are done uh with the
film but um so I invite you all to enjoy
um watching this film and staying for
the panel discussion afterwards
okay so um I would like to invite Dan
and Irma for the panel discussion but
before that let me give you a brief
introduction
to Irma who is our Susan Morse Hills
Chief conservator at the Yale University
Art Gallery
and she has had a very long and
distinguished career in the field of
conservation
she was trained
um at the prestigious uh I'm not going
to say it my Italian is not good enough
in Florence where she worked on a very
important conservation projects
involving paintings by Peter Paul Rubens
and 2000 she came to Yale as a guest
conservator
and then joined Yale fully in 2004.
and she is the chief conservator and I
am delighted to have her to be in
conversation with Diane today please
welcome
now it's something to be seeing an image
of this from Diane's laptop
so it's quite a treat thank you for that
I think the mics are working they're
working yes
um so I think I'd like to give Amma the
opportunity to ask a question or two
before we open it up to the audience and
and continue okay
so I have a question for you which is
um
if um
closer to the mic
is it on yeah it is oh okay my question
to you is
um if you
um had found the painting in a museum
setting and
um would you have changed your approach
to conservation and in particular to
um
to the Reconstruction of uh the areas of
losses if you feel like in a museum
setting you would have like sort of
approach things slightly differently and
if perhaps you would have used a sort of
advisory committee to help
that process prior to actually your
restoration
well it's it's a scenario that that
didn't happen and that is very far from
I mean it's just coming from a different
direction the museum owns the Leonardo
da Vinci and they decide to restore it
yes there's a committee and all of that
and you know it's always would be nice
to have that kind of advice
on in terms of my restoration I wouldn't
do anything different
yeah it's a there's um you can't see it
uh you know I this I created this
website
um
and you can go on it and see
there's a image there's an UltraViolet
image of the painting which shows
my Restorations and the uh and the
original
and you can see that that they are they
they can in fact I did an overlay to
also to check myself and you can see
that the that the retouching of in
painting corresponds exactly with the
areas of loss
um and that are also a very important
point is that
the areas of loss are surrounded by
passages of paint that are absolutely
intact
that have that have all the all these uh
thin layers of modeling
um which are you know in the for the
flesh tones there are about five
different very thin paint layers on and
had that and had that not been the case
if as we say in conservation all the
paint had been slightly worn away I
wouldn't have been able to do that
restoration
but I would have had to do something
much more neutral but because there were
these adjoining areas that were so
perfectly preserved
I felt that it was even almost necessary
um in order to you know to
you know to to make them read properly
um to do the kind of restoration that I
did
I
I'm curious about something else you
know I'm a scientist and we have these
little moments of Discovery you know
they may not be earth-shattering
sometimes just the joy of figuring
things out for oneself and of course
there's the dramatic Eureka whatever
that is associated with scientific
discovery I want I
I dawned on you
that moment when you thought you saw it
was a Leonardo what did it feel like
well I had already at that point I had
been working on it for quite a long time
and I knew that
um
by that time I had all the art
historical information about it
Martin Kemp had given his opinion on
and
but I was still for myself not
you know not
entirely convinced or maybe not that I
mean I
to the point where I could you know put
my life on the line and say yes I think
this is by Leonardo it's not by luini
it's not Bible trafio it's you know that
is that this is this can only be by
Leonardo
respect that like the first look already
at the first look no I didn't because it
was I didn't first of all this
you know was um
period when my husband was very ill I
actually didn't want to work on the
picture
I tried Providence was a bit dodgy
no Providence is actually not so I mean
it's not where it was
oh resurfaced right New Orleans and the
sort of obscure yes yes eventually of
course the Wall Street Journal
um Tracy we knew that it was in the cook
collection so it's not that it didn't
have any provenance it's just that
there's no provenance before 1900 but
that's true of many many pictures uh
so um
so I I didn't you know in the beginning
I really
um
I do really didn't feel that I had the
kind of time or energy to do it and I
was taking care of Mario and he was not
really really not well at that stage and
it wasn't until I showed it to him
and he reacted the way he did
um that I decided to to take it on
because
he hadn't um
I mean it was clear he thought it was
something serious worthy of
Investigation yes he's in fact he
mentions this by a very great artist to
generation after Leonardo Mario had
studied extensively early Leonardo which
he knew really well
so this quite late Leonardo in a way is
kind of
something like the Next Generation so it
so it kind of eventually all makes sense
but it the fact that he
he responded to this and he hadn't
responded to anything
you know for
almost a year
and you know I would try to show him
paintings show him catalogs and he would
just rush them away so this was it was
something you know he took it he took it
in his hands and he looked at it you
know for a very long time
and then you know and he you know and
then he said no this is by a very great
artist and so I thought well wait a
minute I'm missing something
um
yeah that
that you should look harder yes yeah
um we'd like to open up uh we will
continue the conversation but if anyone
has a pressing question and would
the The Walking mic is behind you
uh I was just curious uh so the
Providence has been established through
1900 and then I guess a Wall Street
Journal article will tell me how it got
to the auction house in Louisiana and
selling for a thousand yeah it's also on
my website okay and did you know
anything about the provenance of the
damage to it could you analyze like
their Splinter so a piece of wood went
through it and why it how it got from
being part of the king like the King
Charles
to being something that somebody stored
somewhere it was a discard vulnerable
yeah yeah thank you
um I um
it had it the painting it had an English
cradle a cradle is a kind of a wooden
lattice
that's glued to the back of a panel to
keep it straight
and the type of cradle was definitely
English
and I asked um
uh panel paintings ReStore in London
to confirm this which you did and then I
also asked him if he had because I
I've seen little you know where there's
a slight step I've seen you know a
little bit of Shaving down on pictures
from time to time but nothing like this
because someone had clearly taken a
plane
and just
went right through the picture you know
taking off you know original paint it
was just it was a handyman you know it
was
um
and I asked them if they had seen
anything like this
um
and they said they had seen it on tutor
portraits
um
that um from country houses
um so that was just kind of one little
clue
um
that you know that that may that that it
had um
that it was in England in the you know
late 18th early 19th century still
um yes thanks thanks so much for
um
joining us uh this evening and
especially for for sharing your insights
um
curious to know about the uh the thumb
um uh print
whether it was was
analyzed identified
um
what happened to that to the thumbprint
it's not a thumb print
it's it is a
it it's a painted thumb oh okay so I
thought it was a printer No Sleep
artists uh no there are some you know
fingerprints in some paintings by
Leonardo there are some in Geneva
there's um some in the Saint Jerome in
the Vatican but
they're um you know this is just this is
what we we call a pentimento means a
change of mind
and there are other
um there are other changes in the
painting but they're all very slight
um
and
um they're
um I wonder I've I've
always wondered why he went to so much
trouble to make some of the changes that
he did because it meant revising
um uh uh no a whole part of the painting
on
he moved the hand-holding the orb he
moved it
do you move the hand slightly down and
slightly to the left
um and he moved the the um the mantle so
that he could put in two pieces of black
and this caused him to have to change
the whole structure of the
um
of the crossbands those embroidered
bands
and it was I mean it's such a slight
adjustment that but it clearly meant a
great deal to him and this is why
oh it's also it's another I think
compelling reason for the attribution is
that
um
and that he worked on it over a very
long period of time because if you
compare it to people often compared to
the Saint John the Baptist in Louvre
which was painted very quickly
it was painted practically all in one go
and it has these terrible contraction
cracks where the paint slipped
because the paint underneath it wasn't
sufficiently dry
um and and the Mona Lisa also has many
contraction cracks
the Salvatore Mundi has hardly any
cracks at all of that type
um in the in the in the in the paint
layer also the um the Bell pepperonier
has a series of very significant drying
cracks
um so it's I think and then in from the
cross sections you can see on how thin
the thin buildup of these layers of
color
um
so
um and from the from what I think
as far as I can tell from the Naples
copy which is I think the earliest one
um it was probably he probably began to
work on this picture on before 1500 in
Milan
and then continued to work on it in
Florence in Milan in Rome Milan again in
Roman in France I think it was a it was
a long it was it had an extremely long
gestation
oh the mic okay yes I have it here
oh
well the painting was in your position
was it insured
if so by whom I mean not the insurer but
who decided to do that and for what
presumably Earthly amount did it start
at you know I'm assured I I don't really
know because until it went to London
uh and it was
[Music]
um
well at least Robert Simon felt that he
had enough
our historical opinion to say that it
was by Leonardo
um I have no idea what he and shorted
for
after that I I think in fact he said
that the insurance was was becoming very
costly on uh you know that so that
that's one of the reasons they brought a
partner in and anyway but so but I have
no idea what they insured it for
is actually as
as
um
like the NYU faculty from the art
history department or students where
they sort of like
coming to sort of like look and offer
advice or provide opinions no now I
worked on it
um usually on weekends or I would begin
in the late afternoon and work on it in
the evening uh the only person the only
colleague that um
I asked to look at it
um is um Dorothy Mann
um so
uh it you know it wasn't the
I just needed to work it out for myself
oh I see
take me out before I can ask a question
um
uh I I guess my question I have two
questions
um you know in the film uh they talk
about the best conservator in the world
Etc and I wanted to know what makes
someone as a conservator the best
conservator oh that was just silly I
know but I I just I mean they did they
just made that up you know it's just
about what
[Music]
what would esteem a conservator and also
I was wondering
um how you felt like when you were doing
the retouching you separated yourself
from the hand of the artist and yourself
I mean I'm an objects conservator and my
first uh my first real knowledge of in
painting techniques or are from Irma who
uses a very uh a visible into painting
technique which I feel like you I
understand her approach in separating
her own technique from the techniques of
the artist and I was wondering what your
approach was to to
you're in painting well I I tried to I
I tried to imitate the entire layer
structure
working in myself in very thin layers
for example in the flesh tones
um the first Leonardo's first layer is a
very deep pot pink so I underpainted it
with that
and then it was just a kind of series of
you know very thin glazes and scumbles
and then editing you know I was
constantly you know you know take taking
off what I had put in and sort of paring
it down a bit and
um which also burnished it until to make
sure that it wasn't hadn't gone outside
the limits
um
um but that it was you know that I mean
that's all actually that's how I work
always anyway
um so
I mean it sounds like you're imitating
what was built up from rather than
you know
creating something like a visual
reconstruction rather than
uh I don't understand what you mean yeah
you look at it up close would you be
able to tell your brush Strokes from
Leonardo's brushstrokes whereas if you
would look up close at some oh like
something that's done yeah for example I
can see that they're tiny ones but like
if I step
step away I can it comes together as a
complete picture
no you would have to you would have to
be very very close to the picture indeed
to be able to see them
yes
well I have this I have this ultraviolet
uh image
which is part of the documentation
I don't work that way
yeah
it's a different job technique right
yeah it's a different approach and I've
always you know it's a it's kind of an
Italian approach
and I've always
um in all my training from the you know
from
from the you know from the very
beginning
I've always worked in this way to try to
imitate the adjacent original as quickly
as you know as
um as well as possible
um but there are all sorts of different
problems that come up with every picture
you know as I said this particular
painting had
perfectly preserved passages of original
next to losses which which this which
this Carpenter whoever worked on had
planed right down to the wood so
um
I um
you know I could have um
you know that so that was the you know
say that was the only reason the reason
I could do it it it's it's not you know
but and if you had you know different
kind of picture the different kind of
damage something that's you know
extremely abraded
um where you sort of work you know all
you know to tone down little losses all
over the picture until you got something
that's more cohesive but it's just uh it
changes with every you know with every
picture there's not a formula that you
can just say oh this is this is what you
do but I mean I have a formula for my
materials right so actually that's a
question I have for you when you're
talking about the sort of the five
layers
is the chemical composition of the
pigments are we able to it's a naive
question are we able to completely
reproduce the compositions that he might
have used now
um no because for one thing
um
we don't use lead White
on
and I don't I I don't know and of course
it's it can be poisonous but
um I I I think that I would be afraid
that
the medium that I use
um wouldn't bind it well enough so that
it wouldn't react with the atmosphere
and Blacken right
so instead two potential damage so
you're very worried about that so
instead I'm most conservatives use a
titanium titanium oxide the rutile form
Crystal form which is uh which is stable
it's not as opaque as lead white
um
and there are colors that you can't use
because he probably I mean they probably
had organic pigmentation right which is
there are some colors that faded
that you you know that that you can't
use there are some
um you know there are yeah certain um
you know colors that that alter like you
know realgar or pimento that you know so
you have to substitute
materials that are stable yeah
so I I believe I noticed two different
frames on the painting yeah can you tell
me anything about that well you know the
original really fancy one like out of
period yeah well they did um you know a
lot of this uh of this filming they did
they were reenactments
so the painting the frame that was that
that was on the painting when they sold
it
um
which is at uh this it's this Frame yeah
obviously that didn't have any more but
um but Robert Simon still had the frame
that had been on it when he bought it
which was the frame that was that was on
it when it was in the cook collection
because it still had the inventory
numbers of the cook collection on the
back of it so on
so that so that's what the frame so that
the gold frame that you see that's
that's the cook collection frame
so I was curious
um sort of the chemistry of the
Reconstruction of these colors like I
would like to hear a little bit more
um well so in in terms of reconstruction
of law areas of losses well
um in I would say in Italy we have
a tendency to use a visible in painting
technique for loss
um and it's a lost compensation it's a
theory that was developed in the late
1930s early 40s by cesare Brandi who was
a was to be considered the father of the
Italian theory of restoration of modern
theory of restoration where he
um and the Moda
Paolo in Laura Maura developed this
technique that is called where you use
vertical
um lines you juxtapose a new superimpose
pure colors or you mix Max of two colors
and you create this grid and the whole
point is to hold back the personality of
the conservator so you're reconstructing
like almost that there is like some sort
of filter between uh the work of art and
the conservator and that your
reconstruction is visible and judgeable
so that when you so there's a separation
that's in built build basically the yeah
it holds back that gays The Gaze should
be able to discern yes
so when you're close up you see the area
of loss you can recognize and judge the
work of the conservator when you're far
away you don't so you basically value
the his you have you try to come to
balance the historical value of the work
of art by not
um imposing your own work and then from
an aesthetic point of view you still
allow the work part to be appreciated
because we also made whole right I mean
part of part of the challenge uh
different ways of looking at it yeah is
what way do you want to make this thing
whole and back yes and how you let the
artist be the predominant voice and not
the restorer yeah and there yeah that
that and there are various ways of
thinking about that and doing it
um but I I love the the sort of there's
a detective aspect to all of this which
I have to admit yeah to conservation in
general sort of trying to figure out you
know what was Leonardo thinking like why
did he why did he change his mind right
change his mind that's the
question I don't know there if how many
scientists there are here but um I see
several okay yeah
so the the the orb uh is something that
has been very much discussed
um art historians ah it's actually a
rendering of the globe yes of the world
yeah yes I think it's meant to be the
cosmos I would love to have a long
discussion with you about this sometimes
um that it's supposed to be the cosmos
and
um because the whole painting has to do
with eternity and and you know and and
time and um and at the at the lower
right on the bottom there you can't see
them very well but you can see these
little dots yeah and
um
um a geologist
he gave up on it oh he did yeah but um
it was in here they had they had sort of
had a fight and so the other one was
one more Garcia uh Ruiz uh has kept on
with this and he's
um
these um these are the little white dots
are
he's absolutely convinced our fluid
inclusions in the crystal ah okay and
not some art historians insist that
they're air bubbles I see and he says no
no it's not they're absolutely and this
is quartz crystal and
he's hesitated to publish this because
it has a lot of implications for the
history of crystallography right
because it would make Leonardo the first
person to have observed and studied
crystals as well
that he did right
yeah yeah I think um that's really fast
it hadn't occurred to me until you just
pointed out that I think what's very
interesting um I don't know a whole lot
about the actual solid orbs but I do
know about the maps the versions of the
universe the way the sort of the
cartographic
one-dimensional representations so be
very interesting to see if this kind of
maps on
to some other rendering of the cosmos it
would from that time and you know of
course it's it's the that that the only
part that's well preserved or where the
inclusions are and the rest of it is
very abraded but there are those three
white dots which are original
and that must
signify something looks like the
Pleiades but I don't want to be quoted
on that but yeah yeah someone someone
suggested that it was oh what is it um
or something like that it was it yeah I
can't remember the name of them now
there's this um rendering of one of the
earliest renderings in the western world
that survived it's called the nebra sky
disk and it's actually a copper plate
and it has it has the three it has the
Pleiades and it has the Sun and the Moon
and we don't know what it was used for
or whatever but uh it's very curious
yeah worth uh yeah we should have an
offline conversation no geek out on the
possibilities of which constellation it
might be yeah
but um I was also very curious right
that
is there there is a real difference in
the Blues right on the um
on the fabric the Shroud and the folds
and that orb I mean the there is a very
clear outline right where the orb sort
of ends and uh
yes there's there is uh look at the
clean State you have to see I did does
some work with watercolor do you could
see the edge is to Define it but
what should
what should happen and it you can sort
of see it but it's but it's damaged uh
is that
the drapery seen through the orb should
be magnified right that's where I was
going I was going about whether this was
actually a glass orb or is it actually
Agate or something else yes you know
what I mean if it's opaque material yes
and I think it's meant to be transparent
translucent right because you're I think
you're seeing the fold of the drapery I
think so but um it yeah it's damaged
because there's a painting
um there's a Salvatore Mundi by door in
the Metropolitan Museum of Art it's
unfinished and he also has and has an
orb and because it's not finished you
can see but you can see very clearly
that he that it that the drapery folds
are magnified behind me or what time are
we talking very well preserved about the
same time
yeah so they were definitely
um grinding glass at that point and
making lenses uh in the Netherlands
so Galileo gets it in 1602 and before
that there are these spy glasses and
they already knew how to grind lenses
very well
turns out that Spinoza was one of a
master lens uh the Espinoza was a master
lens grinder actually so that's very
interesting yeah yeah well this is I say
that um
it's uh
so I I mean um you know when I saw this
um so I saw this documentary sometime in
the summer it's on Netflix by the way
and
um to me you know as a layperson not a
professional in this field but kind of
obsessed with art in general and in love
with it
what clinch did for me was the
observation that you made about the lip
Mona Lisa's lip or the lack of the lip
as it were right yeah and so is that um
was that for you also somewhat
convincing yes yeah because I was having
such a hard time with that it's still
not right
um but you know that is big and it's um
because it's there's it's it's just like
blowing smoke you know that is
that that transition so
um what do you think of the lip Mona
Lisa's lip versus Salvatore mundislip
I think it's um it's for me it's very
hard because I actually haven't seen the
painting in person so I I in one sense I
would have loved to
um have that sort of one-on-one yeah
since for me actually the the question
of the lip brings another question it's
like how do you read or through areas of
loss because that is the biggest problem
is like
and to sort of like consider losses such
um
you know like elements of noise and that
we sort of want to you know mock them or
and so how do you get those moments of
like oh I can recognize the hand of one
artist or another one through those
fragments of colors and I think
know and
at least here we have so many students
fellows and interns that come in and
and one of the you know great aspect is
to give them that sort of close looking
and teaching them how to actually go
beyond those areas of damage and really
focus on those but I mean look I mean
but I think one thing is quite clear
that at the end of the day there is a
lot of subjectivity yes oh absolutely
you have the best equipment you have the
data but
um and it is
um
it's something that is highly highly
subjective right that is very very clear
and um and I have to admit that I did
see that Leonardo exhibit in London
but all the the drama about the painting
came after yes so when I saw it it
didn't even occur to me that it may or
may not whatever because you know I was
one of the crowd who thought okay there
it is yeah and uh so it's been
fascinating yeah that it it all the
drama erupted
um yeah that when well when uh when
Christie's yes yeah I guess when I mean
I guess when money got entangled with it
is when I guess a lot of um although the
first some people like the Jerry Volk
owner Salk Jerry sulk is very funny yeah
he's extremely funny but anyway but he
now he got all upset about it um
uh when they made the attribution at the
London exhibition yeah and also Jacques
Franco in there that's so
but anyway but it wasn't it didn't reach
that didn't have that fever pitch until
it was sold
so um
so one final question before we head out
to the reception yeah there's a question
in the back I
I don't think that the um
was it pentimento was with that your
Discovery would kind of ensure that it
wasn't an original because
a copyist who's a protege who can paint
that well wouldn't paint what they're
seeing wrong that wrong exactly yes
exactly and a forger could do it to make
it really look authentic but I is that
has that ever happened where forger has
actually painted in the pentimentos as
well as the final product probably
probably some of the most so clever but
there
but um but it is I said it's it's very
telling but when you're talking about an
attribution to Leonardo yeah uh yeah
that's thing I mean yeah it's definitely
a pentiment but
um still could have been by luini or
somebody else so
yeah so anyway
um let's uh thank Diane again and Irma
for
foreign
[Music]
yeah
foreign